now phil uh where are you i am in fall
river massachusetts oh my god folks i
know fall river uh i'm from
brookline so not too far a drive away
and um and everybody knows fall river uh
because i'm a murder buff fall river is
where uh lizzie borden
uh supposedly
uh killed
her father and stepmother is that right
that's correct and uh i actually work at
the lizzie borden house as luck no you
don't do you do you really yeah i do
what do you do there um i give tours
so oh you give for a second i thought
it'd be really funny if you said i'm
murdered
yeah you put on a dress and your job is
to kill at least two people a day um
wow i am i gotta say this is really
exciting because
i'm a murder buff and i grew up
hearing about uh
the lizzie borden murders and sort of
thinking about them and i guess there
was some controversy you know lizzie
borden never admitted to it are you uh
are you convinced that she did it my
answer changes every single day so i
always feel like it's a cop-out when
people ask me that question i think most
of the time i say yeah lizzie borden did
it but the more time i spend in that
house
well maybe the crazier i start to feel
but i second-guess everything yeah
yeah yeah well you know what's
interesting because there was a uh kids
used to taunt lizzie borden by saying
there was this song that they sang this
is like in the 1890s you know lizzie
borden took an x
gave her father 40 whacks when she saw
what she had done she gave her mother
41. and i was thinking
whenever i think about that song now i
think oh she's just obsessive-compulsive
that's a description of someone with ocd
like well just give my dad 40 whacks
it should be 41 next time like if she
had a sibling they would have gotten 42.
exactly exactly and she would have been
real precise about it i feel like in
massachusetts though i feel like we just
come out of the womb knowing that rhyme
like it's just in case right yeah no i i
i knew that song as a kid and uh
you know a great our grandmother lived
with us in our house when we were
growing up for a period of time
and um what year was the murder was it
in the 1880s or the 90s 1892 yeah so i
think my grandmother would have been two
years old so
um when that murder happened i think she
was born in 1890 and uh she often tried
to murder us with
she had a little axe so i think it was
just something people did back then i
think trying to murder yeah yeah she
just was like hey man this is what we
did back in the 1890s for fun yeah there
was no tv yeah they didn't have tv they
didn't have the internet and so everyone
was given a little axe and they were
just constantly chopping at each other
yeah that's it just adorable battle
royale
so uh i'm pretty sure she did it i have
to tell you i'm just looking at the
facts and as i know them and she was uh
she was a weird lady she was a
legitimately weird lady lizzie board
yeah you know it's it's interesting
she's one of the most fascinating
figures in american history and yet
there's still so very little we know for
sure about her
and as you can imagine even in the
second half of her life after she's
acquitted of the murders uh she's not
going to be extra talkative with folks
um so i think she played her cards very
close to the vest for the rest of her
life and and went to her grave with a
lot of secrets you know it's uh i mean i
know all these
crazy things about that murder but one
thing i know
correct me if i'm wrong there was a
period of time where they turned that
house
into like in the 1980s
you could stay there right 80s and 90s
you could stay there overnight it was a
bed and breath yes you can still stay
there yes it's still the best you're
kidding yeah come on now
hey wait a minute guys is that true we
could stay there no we should go on a
field trip is it haunted um i happen to
think so the more time i spend in that
house the the more creeped out i get but
you let's talk to other people who spend
the night and had the best sleep of
their lives you know i think it depends
what what kind of mentality you're
bringing into it um yeah would you be
scared yes i would not i would not i
wouldn't either i wouldn't either i know
i feel yeah i just you know i what
what's going to happen people were
brutally murdered in there yeah scared
of ghosts or supernatural i'm worried
about actual living humans that will
kill you so as long as that's not going
on there i'm fine right well if we all
go to if we all go together uh the
overwhelming chance matt is that i will
kill you so so i am afraid of that that
you didn't let me finish that's a
legitimate fear i'm proposing that the
three of us do
a podcast from the lizzie borden house
wouldn't that be fun yeah and we set up
a fourth mic just in case just today she
drops by and she shows up and she's like
hey lizzy
um longtime listener big fan
uh you know i love i love the way you
read ads and then we're like lizzy
thanks for dropping in did you do it oh
come on yes i did it
statue to limitations yeah i hated my
father and man my stepmother was a pain
in the ass any hoots gotta run